and on the good side we're seeing the
highest growth rate in decades the
fastest decrease in unemployment at this
point ever since 1950.
jobs are up wages are up values up and
savings are up
but we're we got problems too
many people remain unsettled about the
economy and we all know why
they see higher prices
they go to the store online or they
can't or they go the store or go online
and they can't find what they always
want
and when they want it
and we're tracking these issues and
trying to figure out how to tackle them
head on
let me explain the part that the ports
play set why they're so critically
important
the house of representative passed my
bipartisan infrastructure bill along
with another plans that i'm advancing
this bill is going to reduce the cost of
goods to consumers businesses and get
people back to work
helping us build an economy from the
bottom up in the middle out
that where everybody's better off and so
look this is a once-in-a-generation
investment
to create good paying jobs
supply chains are incredibly complex
as long as goods and materials
are getting where they need to go on
time
there's usually no need to worry about
the supply chains
but
when global disruptions hit
like a pandemic they can hit supply
chains particularly hard
kova 19 has stretched the global supply
chains like never before and suddenly
when you go to order a pair of sneakers
or a bicycle or christmas presents for
the family you're met with higher prices
and long delays or they say they just
don't have any at all the reason for
that last year
was has a lot to do with most companies
make their product how they make their
products today
instead of pointing fingers
we're seeing folks start to work
together
railroads ocean liners labor
state and local governments
the progress has already begun and now
we've passed the bipartisan
infrastructure bill the deal it's only
going to accelerate
you've heard me say it before
infrastructure infrastructure used to be
rated in the united states as the best
in the world the bottom line is this
with the bill we've passed last week
and the steps we're taking to reduce
bottlenecks at home and abroad
we're set to make significant progress
we're already in the midst of historic
economic recovery
and thanks to those steps we're taking
very soon we're going to see the supply
chain start catching up with demand
so not only will we see more
record-breaking job growth we'll see
lower prices faster deliveries as well
this work is going to be critical as we
implement the infrastructure bill as we
continue to build the economy from the
bottom up in the middle out
by passing the buildback better plan
we need to unlock the full might and
dynamism of our economy guys
and of our people i really mean it